but there's so many people are so
connected and so energetic
that i think you have to be one step
more
[Music]
hey it's so good to have you on
20-minute leaders thank you so much for
giving your your precious precious time
it's a pleasure to be here wonderful
okay so you know if i start going over
all the things that you've done
i won't be able to let you speak for
those 20 minutes i'll just give a very
brief overview and and we'll fill in the
rest of the details over the next 20
minutes
founded a startup and sold it to bank of
america
senior vice president of bank of america
and then went on
to to be director of various companies
moved on to venture capital
a partner at light speed ventures one of
the most popular ventures
here in in the bay area and now founded
misema ventures investing in early
early-stage startups in israel
and also the involvement with jay
ventures and and we just mentioned the
love for all dead and the capitalistic
kibbutz and bringing together both
israelis and
and and and jewish people from around
the world into this mission
did i did i get a good overview i have
nothing to add it was great talking to
you thank you for your time
i just saved you 14 minutes
but i did forget one thing that i
promised you talk about which is the
fact that you're one of the largest
kosher wine collectors in the world
a real passion of mine something that
i've been doing for many many years
we did our first winery in in 1989 when
we were living in sacramento
and maybe there were 10 kosher wines you
can choose from and
my partner at that time art huntley came
up with the saying
would you boil your orange juice so we
went out to make
really great wines and eventually sold
it to herzog the largest producer
producer of coaster wine in the world
and have been doing wine projects both
here
and in israel uh really for the last 25
years
focused around drinking and drinking
and focused around wine tastings and you
know positioning the industry
to be in a posse a position way better
than it was 10 or 15 years ago
it's you're one of the most world
renowned and you know entrepreneurs
investors and tech executives what's the
deal with wine
why wine you know one of the things that
really drives me is
and we could talk about this a little
later as being a connector how do you
how do you get people
together and i think that wine because
it it holds the
the two components of being kadusha it's
both holy so the friday night table
which is where every friday night we
have 20 people for shabbat dinner
young people older people yeshiva
students stanford students
we have all the time and wine is that
connector it's the middleman
and you can take uh you know a
non-jewish
you know president of daimler uh to to
israel and do a wine dinner on his honor
which we've done
of course and he walks away saying
israel is great but the wine in israel
is even greater
and so i i find wine is really a common
for the most part it's a real
common uh bond between people of the
whole world young
old middle-aged and globally and so
i have a good palette i mean there
aren't a lot of things i have good but a
good palette i have
and so i started collecting and making
and producing
and drinking and it it all it all fits
together
wow incredible incredible so how many
how many bottles of wine would you say
you've produced
over the years well the better question
is how many do i have in my cellar
because what i produced is gone
in my in my cellar here in in oakland
have about three and a half thousand
bottles
and then in jerusalem i have about a
thousand or more
and they're from every known place on
the planet i mean we have spanish wines
italian all kosher spanish italian
obviously israeli california french so
it's quite you have to come it's it's
quite quite diverse
i i am immediately taking you up on this
offer and the minute i heard
three and a half thousand bottles of
wine in oakland and a thousand back in
jerusalem
yeah just unbelievable how many of them
are unique how many of them are
different
well it's a really interesting question
we make
one barrel of something called harlan
harlan is 100 point parker it's the best
non-kosher wine pretty much a napa
and i have a partner and i make a barrel
every year so
i get 12 and a half cases so from 2004
to now
that's definitely the most rare but i
have some very old wines i have a
beautiful seller
so i have quite a few rare bottles
because i have some of the great
herzog's from
1996 and 98 99 that are still good
so and i have the old yardans from 19
from 1984
and 2000 so it's i have quite a few
interesting bottles
okay i have a feeling i'm gonna enjoy
quite a bit coming for shabbat one night
absolutely wonderful it's talk to me a
little bit about this
about your role at svp and bank of
america you know one of one of the
largest largest organizations
you know very a critical infrastructure
and very different
from early stage startups which you're
involved with now so you know
especially with the with the broad
perspective that you can bring now
having invested in so many companies and
seeing you know the whole world
of tech from young to old how how
how do you see your role at svp of bank
of america now
so that obviously i was the i was an svp
bank of america a while ago and i
i'd like to think that everything that
has
shaped my career unlike your generation
that gets to plan
almost everything that i've done uh has
been accidental
and i say that because my dad was a
rabbi he was a rabbi in the same
synagogue for 52 years
his father was a rabbi actually died in
the synagogue
he was 65 years in the same school and
and i had no plan
to tell you the truth i meandered uh i i
studied technology
at the early in the early days but ended
up co-founding a company
that was pre-internet but still had a
lot of the the components of internet
and we did banking software application
migration for banks
and bank of america bought my company um
so they were my exit
and as part of that exit it was very
early in the internet cycle and they
hadn't been doing a lot
in investing in or kind of partnering
with
with internet companies so i spent two
plus years with them
simply helping them find early stage
internet companies
both in the us and i convinced them to
go to israel so in 1999 2000
i started my monthly trip to israel
since then
including during the intifada and i
learned a lot about what the
corporations
want and need from these early stage
startups and then when
i got recruited to lightspeed it was
kind of like i went to the dark side
which is you know where entrepreneurs go
to retire but it ends up you work six
times harder than you ever worked in
your life
and i was able to apply my knowledge
from what i learned at the bank
uh into light speed and then again into
the future
investing i've been doing so what i mean
having gone through so many investments
and spending so many years in in so many
different
venture capital firms do you have sort
of an investor persona of
of how you approach this world and and
the types of things that that you like
to see and that you don't like to see
yeah it's it's the answer is the most
common answer you'll ever get it's about
the people
uh so but i would say for me first of
all because most of what i do is in
israel
it's about the nexus of california and
israel uh
very very important that the businesses
that we look at now
that is all true up until nisma which i
started in 2016 because that's much more
focused
on the east but up until then the vast
majority of my focus was really on
building cal companies in california and
uh and israel so great entrepreneurs
i for me more than anything work ethic
it's gonna sound strange but for me work
ethic is about as important
as anything else that i look for how
quickly do i get my emails returned how
quickly really phone calls
you know if if we talk about you'd like
to meet someone in company x and two
weeks later you send me that
information i'm not interested in
investing in you if if
in that so that's that's one of my first
tells of first signs
is work ethic uh energy i want to focus
on this because this is fascinating and
i don't get to talk about this often
talk to me a little bit about this you
know the efficiency
and and responsiveness that you're
looking for because this it also seems
almost this is kind of a new age idea
that
we need to be very responsive we need to
be we need to
to to you know be very communicative and
sort of all the time with our phone
so talk to me about this approach of
yours so i
even even back to the well i started in
the 80s remember
but even in the 80s and the 90s uh if i
got a phone call
i returned that phone call if i had a
list of to do's to do for the day
i didn't go to bed until i finished that
list of to do's and so
for me it's been it's been kind of my
dna from from the beginning
but i think what the problem with today
is that
there's always someone better than you
there's always someone working harder
there's always someone more engaged and
at the end of the day the person who's
going to win that race clearly it's
about intellect and working efficiently
obviously that's true
but there's so many people are so
connected and so energetic
that i think you have to be one step
more
in order to really beat the guy next to
you because you only have to beat the
person next to you it's not about you
know there are five competitors
you want to be the one or the one of the
two that win it's like the joke that my
that i think my father always told me
that if you're in a forest
and you're with your friend and a bear
is chasing you you don't have to outrun
the bear you have to outrun your friend
yeah and you know what that's a great
story and that's how i would say
one of the key aspects of people when i
look for people
that's what i'm what i'm looking for
interesting so
besides the responsiveness and and the
clarity how they communicate
is there are there other aspects about
their work ethic that you're able to
sort of judge
along your due diligence process or
simply the relationship that you're
building with them
no obviously i i especially in israel
because i've been there
since 2000 i i rely on a very heavy
network
of um of people now your generation is
different than mine
so if i were to ask you know if i were
to ask about what unit you were in and
what you did there i
you know the truth is you can most
probably trick me all day long because
i'm just not
even on there every month and so at
misma my new fun
which we've been doing for almost four
years we have an ex-air force pilot
f-16i pilot named yoav who
will look at you in 30 seconds no right
and then we have uh my oldest son who
did his degree
at princeton in cyber security and my
middle scenario just popped in
um he he he he looked at a thousand
companies last year
and then we have this guy rick kaplan
who was the former ceo of ibm
in israel et cetera so what i what i'm
able to do is
use their on the ground current
knowledge and then i could call your arm
teeth the ceo of
ernst young and you know he says yes now
let's talk you know you can sit back and
relax with the guys you smoke cigars
with
and drink whiskey so it's kind of like a
two-faced approach and i'll know
everything there is to know about you
so that's critical along with the work
energy and your creativity
to really help and of course what you're
doing and who the competitors are but
that's traditional for everybody
i think it's incredible so today you
know even though all the information is
sort of out there and and accessible and
you know all our social media profiles
we you know
people in my generation just love to use
them to not brag but to showcase our
sort of our professionalism and that
sort of where we wish the due diligence
would take place you're approaching this
much more personal relationship oriented
place of
we understand the cultures and when and
we know the right people
and we we can actually get to the bottom
of who you are we don't have to rely on
on these more superficial titles that
you might give yourself on linkedin
or elsewhere it's a great summation i'll
add only one thing to that
what i've found throughout my career but
more now than ever
by using some of the metrics and
criteria that i have
when the chips are down and the chips
are going to be down
um it's you i can depend on that are
going to go that extra mile spend the
extra day
be the extra honest versus summers uh
i'm going to throw in the towels so that
it all builds up to nuts when the times
are good that's pretty easy it's when
the times are bad i focus i i plan for
definitely so you've you've had you know
the the the pleasure of seeing
a few bad moments in in our economy
during your tenure as a venture capital
uh partner
both you know the 2008 crisis that i'm
looking at but also covet 19.
do you see some do you actually start
seeing
these aspects come out and the
entrepreneurs that you've invested in
and how they deal differently with these
crises and and whether their leadership
emerges or sort of
uh succumbs oh
it's like after the first hour meeting
not
when we start with them but in in these
times the differences
across some of the ceos both in our
portfolio
plus i've been investing for a long time
so i have other other investments across
different businesses
it's stunning the differences the people
that after our first
meeting uh have already come up with
solutions
we've created this concept it's really a
cool concept called a growth committee
even though it may be a bit of a
misnomer in which we take two of our
partners
and then another vc who's in our deal
and the ceo
and we meet every week every 10 days to
talk about how can we help the company
in this time
and some ceos have have changed their
businesses have changed
the direction have leaned into it and
then they say now help us
some of them and it's not just our
companies of course say can you help us
what should we do how can we do it when
do we do it
okay we're gonna of course going to help
but the difference
in that conversation is is huge
and and so we're seeing a lot of
difference both in the ceos
and how they react to these this crisis
incredible incredible
i'm going to be a little bit selfish now
i'm going to ask for some personal
advice because
it's pretty rare that i have the
opportunity to to chat for for 20
minutes with somebody like you so
it's i know i'm starting my journey like
a lot of my friends both in 8200 and at
stanford we're starting our journeys
we're we're
trying to become experts in these
different fields whether they're in
cyber security
or ai or diplomacy or whatever and now
we're going to go to the real world and
we're going to have to
to figure out ways to make a true impact
and
my life goal as i'm starting to narrow
it down is to really move the needle to
create stuff that has a positive social
impact
connect the the jewish world and the and
israelis
properly i know that's something that
you're also very passionate about
and you know over your years of
experiences and seeing thousands upon
thousands of companies successes and
failures what are some you know pro tips
that i can take with me
you know more personally and so that i
can you know keep on this grit and
resilience
well the first thing i would do is i'll
join i joined j angels
because the very mission of what they're
doing is in line with what you're saying
so that'd be number one
number two this is tangential to what
you ask
but it'll it'll come back and it's
something that if i
ever stop doing zoom calls and emails
i'm going to do and i'm going to write a
book on mentorship
to me there is nothing more important
than mentorship
you know it says in pierre chavos you
know make get yourself a rabbi it
doesn't mean a rabbi get yourself
it really means get yourself a mentor
and
not one but three if you can and from
the walks of life that you think you
want to
participate in now you can't just put up
a dollar bill and get a mentor it
doesn't work that way as you know and
read my book in 10 years from now you'll
get the hints but
but it's a very very important component
of what i would suggest to any
person starting because you have a lot
to learn you know a lot
but you have a lot to learn so i'd say
that's number one and number two
define your goals not i'm going to go
into cyber i'm going to go into ai
that's good but i would call to find
your goals i'm going into technology
into deep technology okay
so now i have a bucket and i know that i
want it to be in israel and i don't want
to
help humanity okay well maybe it's
something in the digital health space as
an example
or there are so many great companies
springing up for the
you know how do you solve the problem in
loneliness in the elderly
you know define a problem that is fits
the criteria
or your criteria that fit the problem
and then who are the best people
in that space who are the best companies
who are the best mentors who are the
best venture capitalists
and i i met a guy who was a
very very senior guy chairman and ceo of
a huge company and the year before a
public company
top five three and the year before 18
months before he knew he was retiring
he spent that time figuring out what
public boards he wanted to go on
but not which companies which sectors
he figured that out and then he said
what are the three best companies in
each sector so he had 15 companies
and then he went out to figure out when
he left he got the boards he wanted so
that's
a little bit later in your career but be
strategic about it without overthinking
it because young people overthink
um be strategic and then go after and
you can do it you have linkedin
you have angels you have your 8200
when i graduated from college my dad was
a rabbi you know how many connections i
had
you're looking at it right here you talk
to my kids or do you you have a hundred
connections that i never could have
dreamed of
how do they fit into your goals it's
incredible because you know so many
people around my community and i'm
having these conversations now with
former
with former soldiers that i've commanded
and with fellow friends at stanford who
are a little bit younger than me
and and they're looking for advice on on
where to go and you know there's this
constant conflict between you know this
company that pays me
maybe you know a little bit more per
month or the company that i'm truly
excited about that is perhaps going to
even teach me more
and it almost seems like there's a
growing social pressure
to make the most amount of money and
your internship or to be in the you know
in the fund that has like the biggest
name or something like that but
i can but that makes me very sad
because you know you know what they say
a guy a guy in my generation will have
10 jobs
a guy in your generation or guy or a gal
will have 10 careers
think about that so that's that's that's
absurd
i mean if you're poor and you need to
put food on the table makes a difference
obviously i'm not talking about that but
if it's a hundred grand versus 80 or 70
or 60 and one you're going to love
i i wouldn't even have that conversation
it's it's so simple right well
i mean i mean definitely i think that
one of the trends that i've been seeing
talking to really incredible people
through this show is that the really
number one
common ground that everybody has is the
passion and i'm talking to people who
have a spark in their eyes i'm seeing
the spark in your eye
the way that you're talking about the
things that you do in life and you know
that's a that's the solution for me to
do things that i that i feel passionate
about that i have this intrinsic
motivation
and making sure of course that there's
foot on the table but at the end you
know
both myself and a lot of my friends are
lucky to have that
and and we have the privilege of going
and exploring the things that we're
truly passionate about yes i want to
thank you so much for the time i have
one last question that i have to ask you
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
or that your wife would use to describe
you like no the ones that my wife would
not work i don't do enough work around
the house i let's not use that um
i would say i'm a connector i love the
people part of anything that i do
uh goal oriented is not fair but i'm
very focused
i get i get a joke in my head and i want
to go find a warning and make that a
kosher
run i'm gonna i'm gonna do that and i'll
i'll tell you not the most important
thing but
don't forget about it let's have some
fun you can oh i
if you talk about people in your
generation who maybe take a better job i
find people just
take themselves too seriously sometimes
it's important
get a cigar box of cigars get some
whiskey get some wine get some friends
and enjoy yourself while you while
you're at the game because you know
you're only here once
i love it i think i think your your
linkedin picture with the cigar is one
of my favorite pictures i've ever seen
of anybody so
uh so it's wonderful i'm going to take
that advice to heart it's thank you so
much for the inspiration for the time
and and i look forward to seeing you in
one of the shabbats uh sooner than you
think
wonderful thank you thank you great
interview thank you bye-bye